welcome back to CBS this morning I'm
Gayle King with Anthony Mason and Tony
to copal there are increasing concerns
about the popular heartburn drugs antic
and its generic version - because of a
chemical that could lead to cancer three
large pharmacy chains in the u.s.
recently pulled the drugs off the
shelves following an FDA alert about an
impurity in the medication zantac is
used by about 2 million Americans every
year dr. Jon LaPook recently spoke to
two groups of researchers who suspect
the problem could be serious for
consumers we take the entire tablet just
as a patient would and we dissolve it
into the solvent at this Connecticut lab
called ballast yer researchers test
drugs from its own online pharmacy to
check for purity and quality last spring
they analyzed a few heartburn drugs to
see if they contained MDMA a chemical
known to possibly lead to cancer that
same chemical have led to recalls of
some blood pressure pills last year so
we're gonna crush this okay one
medication stood out zantac and its
generic version
ranitidine it had levels of MDMA higher
than considered acceptable that was sure
CEO David light back of ingrediens Antec
appears to us to be a fundamentally
unstable molecule light reported to the
FDA his suspicion that the problem is
not just an impurity but what could
happen to the pill inside the body and
in a variety of conditions conditions of
the lab conditions of the human body it
can breakdown and then form the
carcinogen and DNA you're saying the
ranitidine itself can break down and
form MDMA correct that possibility that
ranitidine could be converted into MDMA
inside the body was suggested three
years ago in research published by
William Mitch a professor at Stanford
University in a small study ten
volunteers were given a tablet of zantac
and their urine was tested NDMA levels
were more than four hundred times
greater than what the FDA considers
acceptable the results held up when
adjusted for updated FDA testing
guidelines for MDMA in ranitidine we
weren't expecting to see NDMA itself
forming
through conversion in the body so what
was the implication to you when you saw
that there was so much MDMA in the urine
the implication was that there was
potential cancer risk
three months after Voucher first alerted
the fda to its findings the agency
issued a safety alert saying its own
testing found low levels of MDMA in
ranitidine it is now calling even those
levels unacceptable the agency told CBS
News it is now investigating what
happens to ranitidine inside the body
after it's exposed to stomach acid what
do you think happens going forward now
what would you like to see happen what
we've been petitioning for is for the
complete recall of all ranitidine
products brand generic doesn't matter
doesn't matter who made it or what lot
number it is zan tax maker Sanofi told
CBS News that the Mitch study has
limitations the company also said it is
working with the FDA and doing its own
robust testing while zantac is still
being sold some generic makers have
issued voluntary recalls jon if if
they're calling for a complete recall
here should people stop taking these
drugs well the problem here is there are
so many questions that are unanswered we
do not know the answer to that but I can
tell you that Memorial sloan-kettering
which is a top Cancer Research Centre in
the world has pulled ranitidine which is
the generic form of the attack from its
pharmacy and it is also doing an
investigation to see if people who come
in who are taking ranitidine or santech
have an increased rate of having certain
types of cancers so lots of questions
and we don't have enough answers it's
interesting here it was flak something
was flak three years ago well nobody saw
it or they maybe they saw it and then
they didn't act on it so there are still
so many questions I know it's
disquieting for people they're not happy
here's what you're supposed to do we
always fall back on look speak to your
clinician and talk about the possible
alternatives there are if that's
something that you want to consider
there are lots of alternatives to zantac
and ranitidine alright John thank you
very much